on Netflix jeez Louise no this is
actually coming to Netflix soon
yeah what this is actually gonna be a
Netflix show comedians on skype talking
comedy oh you like that yes for uh
thanks for doing this man
the the hot breath averse is very
exciting they've already been in the
group posting questions so this is gonna
be good so what I'll do is I'll just go
ahead and jump over into the group I
like do a brief intro and then just
bring you right in my friend okay
alrighty here we go alright hot breath
averse welcome to hot breath live this
is the show where you get to ask your
favorite comedians your favorite
questions today is a hot breath favorite
ladies and gentlemen welcome back oh he
knows the breathing welcome back Jeremih
I can't see oh you can't honey oh how do
I add myself oops
I don't know I want to make sure you see
me dude
I want to see ya I gotta get something
oh there we go yeah oh yeah IKEA we're
so cute together just to to pale white
boys dude
couple brothers so let's uh let's jump
right into it the hot breath the versus
steaming with questions I first I've
been asking all the comics this at the
beginning but how are you doing right
now with the the current quarantine
situation how has it affected your work
yeah he looks like he's already going
crazy but how has it affected like did
you have a lot of work that was
cancelled and then how are you
capitalizing on the current time
so yes I did lose a lot of work abouts a
hat what kind of sucks about right now
is I this was like my really busy time
that was going on right now like I was
in the middle of like a nine ten week
run of different weekends and the last
six of them got cancelled so I was
really stoked because just just within
this last year I've been starting to do
my own weekends with headlining and
stuff so I was really excited to be
getting out there and consistently
starting to do my own weekends because
that's you know we're all you know
that's something that we all as
comedians kind of are working towards
for years and years is just to like get
one maybe of your own weekends and I had
I was fortunate enough to get like a run
and yeah those guys cancelled their
rescheduled but I I just don't know how
that's gonna look when you know what I
mean we'll see
other than that I'm staying I'm pretty
fortunate I have a wife I'm very
fortunate that I have someone to be in
quarantine with so that is a blessing
for sure because some of our you know a
lot of our comedy buddies they don't
even have a dog it's literally they just
do the mics and the shows and that's
life in which you know that is a big
part of my life but I'm fortunate that I
was building something outside of
stand-up kind of along the way and I
have that going as well so are you gonna
feel it too right yeah exami I mean I'm
with my wife and I feel fortunate that I
I didn't just like the stage is clearly
like my primary that's my that's my my
baby but I was working on outside
projects as well that are keeping me
busy but then also bringing in some
money with my special you know and and
merch and I'm doing an online class and
things like that so the podcast as well
so luckily I had more than one iron in
the fire but I feel like this is
exposing a lot of people
of like oh I really went all-in on this
one thing that is so fragile you know
yeah none of us knew it was this fragile
exactly exactly yeah this is clearly
leaving sir yeah yeah I so I've been
making money a little bit here and there
just through like just like a little bit
like with merch stuff online and just my
podcast and stuff like that um which I'm
grateful that I have that outlet and
yeah it's funny I've been I've been
plugging my venmo on kill Tony lately
and and Tony Hinchcliffe hates it like
he thinks it looks like he thinks it
looks like begging and I'm just like no
it's just like I just see this right now
like we're providing a service like just
like any other streaming service and
it's not like a beating people over the
head with it it's like hey if you want
to here's this at the end of the episode
if not cool
you keep chugging along you know yeah
and you're creating a lot of content I
mean do you have any tips for comics
Before we jump into their questions here
any tips for comics on how they can make
the most of the current situation yeah
absolutely
this is a big one because and this is
just more of like being a self-starter
and knowing how to do stuff if you I
don't here's the thing I don't know what
where you're at financially but there's
usually I don't want to promote getting
bootleg and pirating like software and
stuff like that but I don't know what
your financial situation is with having
to get certain editing software if you
are a comic in quarantine right now
learn how to edit your own stuff mmm if
you don't know how to edit your own
stuff you are at somebody else's knees
you're held captive by somebody or held
hostage by somebody who may or may not
want to get around to editing your stuff
you know what I mean unless you're
paying them which if you're a comic you
probably don't have the money to pay
somebody to do a clip you know what I
mean yeah so learn that as a skill that
is invaluable it's one of like my things
I know how to photoshop
use final cut and I know how to at least
make my stuff look decent online where I
can throw it up or if I need to turn
around a clip that I need to cut
something out of something I have the
means like just with my laptop I just
have like Final Cut and Photoshop on my
laptop where I can do that for myself so
I mean you know people are telling you
to try to make the most out of
quarantine time but if you're a comic
and you don't know how to edit like use
Photoshop or Final Cut do the online
tutorials I mean they're they're kind of
grueling sometimes and you have to
really force yourself to kind of sit
through it and learn but it's something
that will help you long long into your
career after this is all said and done
with so that's the that's the main
advice that I can say is learn how to
edit that dude that is gold I've been
getting everyone's advice on here with
that the comics we've had but like that
maybe my favorite pieces really use this
time for skill acquisition cuz I could
tell you personally like I I started
learning Photoshop maybe almost eight
years ago completely self-taught as well
you know now I'm more versed in the
Adobe Creative Suite but even like like
I movies a free editing software there's
other totally there's free graphic
design options out there as well can
buzz an option where you can start to
learn the basics of graphic design but
it's all the resources at your
fingertips now is a great time to really
start learning these tangible skills
that will help you to become even more
self-reliant and self-sufficient great
tip man great tip so let's jump into it
and this is this is a good this is a
good first one and speaking of you being
out on the road headlining now which is
so cool because just last year I started
headlining more and getting out on the
road like where you are like the
headliner and it can be scary and it's
it can be a whole new learning curve but
it's and now you feel like a comedian
though when it's like your show and it's
all on you in a sense yeah it's so great
it's great it really yeah the stakes are
much higher because you know if you fail
then everybody has a horrible evening
yeah
a lot of it's a lot of fun it's a great
it's it's great to take on and this this
this may play into that because Charlie
Harper here asked what's the most
unexpected turn or revelation
Jeremiah has seen when doing crowd work
the most unexpected revelation or turn
um you know what I had one show that has
still stuck with me where I was doing I
wasn't even doing crowd work with a this
specific person it was somebody like
just like in the vicinity where like
that's the that's the risk that you take
whenever you open up dialogue with the
audience as they sometimes when they're
drinking it's it's almost always as
somebody who gets too sloppy they see an
opportunity and they capitalize on it
and this lady she didn't near the end of
my show and she just was like super
super negative like like I'm like uh
what do you do for work cuz she kept
talking and she goes I Hackel this is
like and then I was like really that's
that's what that's what you want to do
with this conversation and I it was one
of those things where sometimes you just
shouldn't engage with anybody at all and
it's too late after a moment and she did
it near the end of my show and it like
put a bad taste in my mouth because I
had to like do I had to close like a
couple minutes later and I'm just like
ah I should have just you know I mean
sometimes you should just stay in the
pocket and just keep doing your material
even though you might get tempted
because I mean I'm like a kid in a candy
store but if I see like temptation out
there in the audience where I'm like oh
I could riff I could have fun let's be
silly I go for it a lot of times like
even if somebody says something like
like if you see somebody live there's
sometimes comics who choose to engage
with the audience whenever they hear a
little bit of cross chatter or crosstalk
and they'll plow through which that's
important to do it at certain moments in
your set but other times for me I see it
as an opportunity
okay they're one to talk let's let's
let's mind this let's see let's see
what's going on which that can backfire
a lot so like sometimes you get really
negative people like the lady who you
asked what they do for work saying I had
cold she was just like a horrible person
she by every question that I asked was
like she responded so negative to the
point where I had to do the thing as a
comedian where it got so negative with
her where I was just like listen we're
just all trying to have a good time here
tonight
I mean it's pathetic whatever I
rewatched on videos like not putting out
that clip hello never you're dealing
with weird audience members of course
yeah alright and this this actually
rolls into the next question if we're
gonna improvise into the next one here
as we say it's Christian Williams asking
how do you balance your improv and
stand-up is it possible or should you
focus on one follow-up to them
I don't know I did now are these are
they inside are they able to write in
like while we're live right now uh-huh
or mmm-hmm okay cool I still have a
question for Christian how many years in
a comic
are you that makes a huge that that is
super reliant on the question that
you're asking because if it's one or the
other like you like in my opinion if
you're early on in comedy which I'm only
like I'm still like I just hit like 10
years of being in comedy and I still
consider myself earlier on the early
side of being in the comedy just because
you look at like headliners who've been
doing it for a long time a lot of those
guys have been doing at least 20 years
so I would say be working on everything
if you can I mean obviously you can't
really work on improv too much at mics
like with crowd work but you can work on
your riffing and stuff like that so it
all depends on how far in but I don't
think the
you have to choose between the two
unless you're talking about actual doing
improv like with a group and actually
doing your sole act as a stand-up
I do think you have to choose between
one of those two otherwise you'll get
kind of mediocre both is which which is
what was happening to me the first few
years that I was involved in improv and
stand-up is I had a group things were
going great
I was hitting mics I crazy I was
starting to do a lot of shows but then
the scheduling it just didn't work out
we're like I had to pour my attention
into one and I chose stand-up over like
improvising with a group of people yeah
he's a he's one year into comedy and
four years into improv yeah I mean
what's it really depends what you you
love more what I will say is I don't
know where what part of the country he's
in it's way harder to make a career out
of being an improviser being an
improviser you can get opportunities to
you know book certain commercials and
stuff that'll that opens those kind of
doors and even it's all about making the
relationships with on the improv side
with more so like the casting directors
and stuff it's definitely more of like a
an actor route to go just the improv way
you there are literally compared to the
people who make money at stand-up and
improv it's so lopsided because there
there's not a ton of improv comedy clubs
just look at it on a map just literally
on on that surface level there's
literally one to ten maybe or maybe even
it's a larger margin of how few improv
comedy clubs there are to stand-up
comedy club so maybe some of that info
will help I don't know great all right
the the next one here from skip
says do you have a particular writing
exercise or way of writing that you keep
going back to yeah I like to find a
location that makes you feel creative
for me one of them is the laundromat
because I have a specific time that is
you see a clock that's literally
counting down like 20-some minutes and
it's like okay I have 20 minutes to -
right before I have to change the load
over and then you see you literally see
how much time you have left when a when
your clothes are drying that's one place
where it's like it's an outside thing
but it puts it puts me in a creative
space because it's it's also around
you're not you don't have as many
distractions like I listen to my sets of
a big part of my writing processes I
listen to sets of which is a very
important part of being a comic which is
like the not fun side of the shore is
listening back to your sets yeah because
it's it's something that you don't like
especially if you had a bad set you
don't want to relive that but it's
important to listen back to see where
you kind of went wrong because a lot of
times you can trace it back to an exact
moment in your set and then when you
listen back to it and you take that in
you're like oh here's the list of things
for me to not do again yep like that's
basically what stamp how in my opinion
how I how you see progression with a
comic over the years as you learn the
things not to do over and over again
until you have a truncated list of like
oh if I do this then there's a pretty
good chance that I'm gonna have a killer
set tonight that's how I kind of look at
it is I so much look at things a little
bit more analytical like as far as that
stuff goes if that Gore yeah that yeah
that makes perfect sense and I consider
listening writing like if if I listen
I'm like oh my set okay I did a writing
session that day you know it's that
important
I 100% agree with you on that yeah all
right the next one Alan J Lister will
you have Joel on Jeremiah wonders let's
make it happen sometime yeah yeah I mean
clearly I
I have no doubt we're definitely gonna
be worth either in the future they're
sure I'm you know honestly in the
current state that we're in it's
probably easier now than ever to have
Joel on us because it's one of those
things where you know I've got my
comedian buddies who are starting to
zoom in or whatever the only thing that
I haven't that's a little bit hard about
my show that I haven't necessarily
cracked yet with this new situation is
like my show is very based on me being
with the guests right like I have I
literally have Hardware in the studio
for them to play with so it's just a
different thing and I don't know I
haven't really tried doing too many bits
over zoom yep
but I did do one on this most recent one
coming up where I talked to the writers
of the Sonic the Hedgehog movie and I
put on a wig and stuff and I acted like
an out-of-touch CEO pitching them bad
movie ideas so that's fun so you know
trying to make the most out of them yeah
and you're I mean you're you're super
creative and great improviser so I'm
sure it's only that's what this is
really it's it's forcing you to start
creating in a different way all of us so
we're only just gonna learning and
honing the best way to use the mediums
that we have accessible but so he Allen
he didn't say no he was saying yes
but that's that's what I love about our
relationship is like we've only really
met a few times and it's all just been
more like this but I know we're
eventually going to be actually working
together which is always I'm so cool in
this comedy game you just never know
when or why or who but I mean you know
from you starting your stand-up on the
spot show the name of offs and now it's
like one of the number one shows in LA
you know I mean you know the process of
just consistently putting in the work
staying funny and you'll start to meet
all these different people start working
with them yeah yeah and I've been doing
this fall will be I've been doing
stand-up on spot for 10 years straight
I'm gonna have my 10
in August I believe so yeah
pretty well yeah just keep putting on
your work kids
Bobby J Brooks says would you say comedy
is me would you say a comedy is needed
now more than ever I think yes you know
what I have noticed a shift a little bit
with with when I put out clips the
amount of times that I've seen and this
this is not a normal comment that I
receive on comedy videos but the amount
of comments that I've seen just within
the last couple weeks people either who
I know or people who just follow me
online is they'll comment something like
thank you I really needed this right now
which I think that's a big shift in kind
of where people are at with society
right now is I think inherently because
of the situation everybody's a little
bit more depressed or a little bit more
you know just high strong with their
emotions right now where I think that
comedy is kind of needed a little bit
more now than ever I think it weren't a
weird area where since it's going on
right now it feels a little bit awkward
to be you know shoving stuff out there
but people I think are appreciative of
it and once this all gets settled it's
gonna be I think the comedy shows will
be some of the best shows that we ever
do once this stuff is over because
people are gonna be so desperate to get
out of the house once this is all said
and done with and just feel normal again
and feel like you're bonding with it
with other people which I think one good
thing that will come out of this is I
think that people are going to be a
little bit more grateful for
interactions and I think people are
going to be a little bit nicer to each
other after we come out of this
quarantine because they're gonna realize
I go like I was taking for granted a lot
of things with my life as we all are
kind of
figuring out right now mm-hmm yeah and
it's funny the next comment is actually
from Dana Ramona saying just want to say
thank you and the rest of the till Coney
Tony crew for continuing to put out new
content every week really helping me
keep my sanity intact so that's a prime
example spicy here yeah yeah we're still
doing kill Tony every week I'm southern
Jeremiah wonders every week and more so
with kill Tony it's a you know it's a
group effort and that's a show that was
done in front of a live audience so
that's a bigger shift I think for people
to to to to see where we're taking the
show with it now because it's very
different now but it's kind of exciting
because it's bringing in some new
features that we've never done on the
show before and I think that it helps
make people feel more normal especially
me because on Mondays I'm still going to
do the part of my routine even though
it's not in front of a live audience so
I yeah I appreciate your support my
friend yeah so we have a few more and we
have a few minutes left so what I'm
going to do is a start a countdown timer
so I'll well I'll start doing like a 45
second timer for these next couple
questions are okay and all right and
I'll be short winded on we want to be we
want to be mindful of Jeremiah's
valuable time here so the Dana actually
followed up if you can speak to it how
does the kill Tony and Comedy Store
relationship work financially are you
responsible for packing the house out
and does the Comedy Store get a cut or
is it the reverse and go yeah I hit up
Tony Ames cliff about that I'm not
answering that question
alright we saved some time on that one
the next one MIT wolf what is your
writing process after you've done some
brainstorming can you walk us through a
recent bit from inception to show
this was something that it's the last
actually the last stand of it that I
posted was about the coronavirus which
is you know at this point it's so funny
people are like already like it's hacked
to talk about it shut up it's literally
going on right now I posted a clip
literally before things got real crazy
it was my last like material clip that I
posted and I wrote it in the greenroom
while the other openers on the show were
on stage because I ripped something out
between my friends and I made a comment
to my wife and she just said something
offhand like she's like oh yeah this is
like a germophobes dream come true
and I literally something that I had
ripped and paired with that that she
said him in like it kinda is and then I
went to the greenroom and I literally
wrote the bit and then did it on stage
while it was fresh and I was excited
about it so sometimes I if I'm excited
about something it's more important to
get it to the stage rather than be
nitpicky about how it will come out
exactly because the more you do it on
stage the more that it will form into a
good solid joke boom
all right Patrick Fowler and this is
kind of a common one we're getting in
terms of I mean your characters are
impressions are like in the top 1% of
comedy and I actually we went to detail
on the process on our hot breath episode
if anybody wants to check it out but um
he says when you make a character do you
take time to write jokes for them
immediately or do you let them come out
naturally in the moment 45 seconds go
most of the time unless it's a sketch I
will do it all in the moment but what I
will do is I make sure that I'm
well-versed in the character and
knowledgeable of the character and its
surrounding stuff like that
most recently I did a joke SATA
compression I just watched the entire
series of Tiger King and I made sure
that I knew that character in his
perspective frontwards and backwards so
that way you can feel comfortable
improvising within the care
which will lead to maybe some more
written stuff later but sketch is kind
of a different thing where you have to
kind of research it in kind of a
different way because people have
different expectations when it is
pre-written all right Bravo you nailed
the time on that one too so the final
one and remember if you want to hear
more about his impression technique hot
breath he really does like go headfirst
into that process
so let's this will be the final one here
Annette Annette it was fun it was a lot
of fun except I I don't remember where I
came from but I was I watched like a
clip that you posted recently and I'm
like oh man this guy is so tired like my
face is like it's like I'm here Joe
ready to do your podcast I think you
guys had just done like a big run on the
road and you would like just gotten back
maybe that morning or something because
I remember you did a testimonial after
the interview and you were looking at
yourself in the phone like the road has
not been good to Jeremiah but yeah you
seem to take care of yourself like do
you exercise are you mindful of your
diet like you seem to like keep yourself
somewhat intact yeah I yeah I I did I
did 15 minutes of yoga for a lower back
pain yesterday because I've been sitting
so much like editing and doing different
stuff yeah yeah yeah but it's been
raining in LA lately before that I was
going on walks a lot because just to
escape just being in my apartment during
quarantine yeah but then this week
they're like but really if you can even
stay inside even more I'm just like okay
alright alright but you're the you don't
like kill yourself in the gym but you
like to keep moving every day type deal
stay low active I move around stay
active but I I don't enjoy lifting
weights I can't get it I can't get it I
mean I just skinny buddies arms
it's all good so the final question here
comes from Trent Babb who says what are
some new things you view as hack we
should avoid specifically stand-up new
things
tinder uber this is just my I always
tell this to comics cuz I I just if
you're an earlier on comic I know like
it's um I know that it's part of your
experience to talk about what you know
currently so if you have a day job you
know I'm not gonna say you to not talk
about it
but I would say be careful we're talking
about other jobs because what I'll say
is as an audience member when I hear
that I hear Oh
stand-up isn't his main thing it takes
you out of it a little bit more so and
then I think that you realize if you're
saying like so yes so I work at Target
and blah blah blah people automatically
in my opinion or be like oh he doesn't
do that this whole time and they kind of
discredit to you a little bit and takes
an audience member out of it a little
bit more than you probably want because
you never wanted to an audience member
to start thinking of other things that
are not directly in front of them
because then if they're not thinking of
something that's directly in front of
them they're elsewhere they're not going
to be engaged and laughing as much as
you want them to and that's just like a
little thing that I've always felt like
is when I started comedy I had a day job
at Starbucks I would never talk about it
but now I talk about it like it's almost
like putting a bookmark in certain life
events for later and
also like another thing like when my mom
started dating like she has a new
husband now at I tried to work it out on
stage but it was coming off as me as too
angry because I wasn't over it yet if
that makes sense like I wasn't like
comfortable yet so sometimes you got to
put bookmarks in certain life events and
material and come back to it later and
make sure you never discredit some of
your early ideas because it could be
good you just might not know how to
crack them yet that answer that no hey
we're given we're given applause on that
response that was great and the final
comment Randi skies says yo I love
Jeremiah brah funny as hell so how can
you not love endorsements like that
so Randy did so before oh it's actually
it's actually a female she's um but no
Randy with an AI so she's got some
flavor to her can I not call a female
dude bro this is the H you want me to
call her dudette like it's the frickin
eighties or nineties dude yeah dude I
just I just challenge Joel's views do
you you guys out in LA are so
progressive and above all of us dude
heck yeah man
so is before we before we get you out of
here is there anything else you want the
world to know or comics to know this is
my podcast Jeremiah wonders I'm doing a
lot of experimental stuff especially
right now I've been doing um I've been
doing a couple of new segments called
unprotected sax where I take suggestions
of covers of songs to play on sax and
then also another segment on guitar
called going under going under the
covers where I take your suggestions and
I sing my versions of songs you send in
and I'm and I've been taking more
suggestions for characters and
impressions and stuff like that so yeah
it's a it's a fun experimental time that
I'm in with with a lot of stuff right
now and then on instagram at
my stand-up look in my story highlights
in my profile I have over a hundred
characters and impressions that you can
just scroll through that are all like
eight seconds long do it because it took
me like a couple years to assemble them
from different Jeremiah wonders
different kill Tony shows different
sketches different shows up and a part
of so check that out that's like a fun
little thing to go through my youtube is
Jeremiah Watkins and I put out weekly
clips there so yeah yes yes please hop
read verse support Jeremiah there's a
reason people like Joe Rogan a Bert
Kreischer say he's the next Jim Carrey
because he is one of the most talented
people in comedy and the fact you're
gonna look back on this day and be like
I can't believe I got to ask him
questions directly this intimately so
Jeremiah honestly thank you so much for
taking the time to do this buddy thank
you thank you for having me of course
buddy stay safe out there and we'll be
in touch
all right wishing you and the wife well
have a good day with you and your wife
Jeremiah have good have good be good
love you good love love all right what
if I just kept looking you know as I say